حياه اهلا بك استاذه حياه مساء الخير اهلا
بك في مساء العربيه وشكرا تواجدك معنا
كل عام وانتم بخير يا اهلا بك اول شيء
رمضان كريم
الله اكرم طيب نبدا بردود فعل واسعه
ومميزه صراحه شهدها العمل قررت عينك كيف
كان اثرها عليك يعني كيف شفتي هالتفاعل
والله عطرها كبير طبعا اكيد يعني الحمد
لله انه جاب الارقام
يصبح فيه وهذا دليل ان العمل يحمل فيه
مضمون وقضيه والحمد لله على النجاح ربي لك
الحمد
استاذه حياه احنا جدا سعداء بوجودك معنا
ومنورتينا ومشرفتينا في برنامج مسائل
العربيه الاخباري على شاشه العربيه واليوم
كمان حابين نسال انه هل حياه الفهد هي
التي تضيف النجاح لعمل ما
هي التي تضيف النجاح لعمل ما
على غير النجاح لعمل الناس
[موسيقى]
النجاح نعم
يعني هل هل اسم حياه الفهد هو السبب في
نجاح اي عمل تشاركين فيه
يعني
ما في انسان يصنع عمل نجاح بروحه لازم
يكون معايا يعني رفقاء او او اصحاب
الزملاء اخوانه الكاتب المخرج الممثلين
الكل الفريق كله لازم يكون يتعاون وانا
العمل العمل
تجمع فيه جميع
المجموعه الفنيه للفنانين وفنيين
ومخرجوا بعضهم اكيد راح يكون هذا لا تاثير
على العمل وعلى روح العمل
اللي شفتوها وافتكر انتوا شفت خلفي
وكواليس كان في محبه كثير الناس تحب يعني
كلهم يحبون بعضهم المجموعات جميل والقصه
جميله والمخرج شاب ودمنه جديده ويصبح
للاكبر والافضل فاكيد هذه العناصر كلها
تؤدي باذن الله لنج
اح طيب استاذه حياه يعني امانه كل الاعمال
الدراميه اللي تشاركي فيها بتكون ناجحه
ومميزه ما هي شروط حياه الفهد حتى تقبل اي
نص درامي شو تكون شروطها
الاشتراك في اي عمل حتى تختاري المشاركه
في اي عمل شو تكون شروطك فيه شو معايرك
شلون تغاملين تعملين مع مخرج شاب يمكن
ثاني مره او ثالث مره يخرج او كاتب جديد
عمل او عملين قلت لهم انا ما استغني عن
الدماء
الشارده الفكر الجديد يعني لازم نتعاون
يصير عندهم خبره وانا استفيد من طموحهم
الزايد يبون يسوون شيء جديد انا ما عندي
طلبات انا طلبي الاول هو النص انه يكون
القضيه حلوه العمل حلو فيه يفكر فيه هدف
انه ما ينعم العمل مجرد انه عمل لا لازم
يكون في شيء يعني قضيه نعالجها من خلال
هذا العرض فهذه هذه
الشرط الثاني لان العناصر كلها تكون
متواصله مع بعض نعم
واكيد انت بتطفي يعني انت بتطفي الحياه
لاي عمل حياه تطفي الحياه استاذه حياه
ذكرتي في تصريح سابق انك توقفت عن الكتابه
بسبب اصابه في يدك هل هذا صحيح الكلام شو
اللي صار
والله والله هي مش اصابه يعني مو صعبه مش
جرح ولا اللي طحته الحادث هذا الشيء قضاء
وقدر الله كتبنا
القلم ما قدرت امسك رقم اللي لا يعني
صحيح لكن
تقريبا ثلاث سنوات ما اقدر امسك القلم
يعني ما اقدر حتى لو كتبت يعني كانه واحد
توه مبتدا بالروضه ما حد يفهم ولا ولا
اتحمل بقلم وصرت اكره الورق اكره القلم
فهذه يعني عمره انا لله سبحانه وتعالى
واتمنى ارجع لحالتي سابقه باذن الله لان
الاطباء كل الاطباء يقولون ما في شيء
فالحمد لله على كل حال بس انا عندي قاعد
افكر الحين اني استاهل بشباب بالاول كنتوا
هذه الفكره لكن الحين لانه عندي افكار
حلوه وانا احب التراثين فاحب التراث وعندي
جميله وقصص حلوه
وقتنا استاذه حياه نشكرك جزيل الشكر
نورتينا معنا في مساء العربيه سيده الشاشه
الخارجيه حياه الفهد شكرا جزيلا